[Musique]
Dupuis cette semaine pour ma chronique
je fais quelque chose un petit peu
différent parce que pour
m'inspirer dans ma chronique je parlais
d'un moment d'actualité je parlais d'une
situation j'essaie de la mettre en
contexte
cependant les dernières semaines j'ai eu
quelques fois avoir une discussion
autour d'une question qui revient
souvent quand je vois suggérer un sujet
ou quand je voulais parler d'un fait
d'actualité ça et cette question c'est
mais qu'est-ce qui est autochtone
là-dedans parce qu'on s'entend que je
fais l'émission Queen je vais faire
justement les capsules de parole
autochtones mais qu'est-ce qui est
autochtone dans le sujet de conversation
qu'est-ce qui est autochtone dans ce que
je veux parler parce que c'est quand
même ce que j'essaie d'amener de l'avant
avec mes chroniques avec mon émission
parce que c'est un sujet qui est absent
donc souvent quand on va me demander
qu'est-ce qui est autochtène là-dedans
mais il y a moi c'est un sujet
et ça m'a fait me rendre compte mais
dans le fond qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
autochtone comme sujet c'est vraiment ça
la question que j'aimerais poser
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas un sujet dans
lequel une point de vue une opinion
autochtone pourrait village de encore
une fois comme le grand panier de toutes
les nations diversifiées de toutes les
positions géographiques qu'on peut avoir
sur la planète qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
autochtone donc ce qu'on veut dire c'est
qu'est-ce qui est automatiquement exclu
de la conversation pourquoi j'en parle
parce que on a vu dans les dernières
semaines la conversation autour des drag
queen on a eu entendu parler aussi tous
des enjeux par exemple lié à la science
l'absence des sciences autochtones par
rapport au Jour de la Terre par exemple
dans le fond la question qu'on doit se
poser c'est qu'est-ce qui est exclu de
la conversation qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
fait part pas partie du calcul
mathématique de la réflexion sociale et
c'est là qu'on voit le problème c'est
pas qu'est-ce qui est autochtone c'est
où est-ce qu'on peut nous nous adresser
à un sujet nous nous y intéresser ou
même amener un point de vue qui serait
issu de notre expérience de vie en tant
que peuple autochtone c'est de dire
sujet là pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit
absolument avoir un chemin de parcours
et qu'on peut pas avoir une discussion
au cours de ce sujet-là d'un point de
vue autochtone c'est parce que notre
point de vue notre regard n'est pas
encore totalement compris totalement
inclus il manque des facteurs
mathématiques à la société présentement
et ses facteurs-là sont soit autochtones
peuvent même être à l'automne du côté
des femmes par exemple
aussi manque de vision afrodescendante
des nouveaux arrivants qui viennent
s'installer sur le territoire et dans la
vision de leur de leur vie de leur
d'anticie culturel va changer selon
qu'ils sont encore dans leur pays
d'origine qu'ils ont été obligés d'être
forcés à se déplacer de nos visions
sociales sont influencés par les
expériences qu'on a vécues donc dans les
questions de qu'est-ce qui est
autochtone dedans on parle surtout de
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas été inclus donc
dans tout ce qui était de l'aspect des
drag queen je dis oui mais les drag
queen l'idée des drag queen justement
c'est manque toute l'aspect de dire mais
qu'est-ce qui a été empêché dans la
culture des personnes qui sont
bispirituelles d'atteindre la société
qu'on va dire normal qu'est-ce qui a été
bloqué justement avec quand je regarde
de mon point de vue de femme autochtone
la culture autour des doigts Queen parce
que je vois c'est surtout où est-ce que
c'est quoi leur réserve où est-ce qu'ils
ont été limitées pour se développer pour
se faire entendre où est-ce qu'on veut
les voir oui où est-ce qu'on veut pas
les voir parement pour les autochtones
donc cette conversation là elle n'a pas
encore eu lieu parce qu'on manque
d'aspect culturel mathématiques
justement des gens qui ont été exclus et
qu'on voudrait inclure donc dans les
bibliothèques dans la vie de tous les
jours pourquoi est-ce qu'on force la
vision qu'on a des personnes qui sont bi
spirituelles dans une vision très hyper
sexualisée comme si toutes les personnes
bi spirituelles étaient uniquement dans
leur sexualité alors qu'elles ont des
apports naturels qui sont importants et
on le voit par l'expérience autochtone
du passé que c'était très présent dans
la communauté quand on ne leur donne pas
juste la scène des bords la scène des
tout cet aspect là n'est pas discuté
parce qu'on n'a pas encore pu intégrer
ce cette conversation cette calcul de la
conversation là dans la conversation
plus large on a encore entendu juste les
conversations dominantes les opinions
dominantes se faire entendre sur la
grande scène et là c'est pas la seule
chose parce que ça m'a fait aussi penser
cette semaine au fait que il y a un
groupe de jeunes du primaire dans le
grand nord des jeunes inouïe qui ont
inventé un nouveau langage mathématique
qui va inclus dans les calculs puis dans
les programmes de Silicone Valley donc
il manque même une réflexion au niveau
du milieu scientifique les aspects
autochtones de la culture des aspects
des femmes aussi parce que les femmes
ont été exclues des sciences pendant
très longtemps des personnes
afrodescendantes justement des milieux
universitaires donc toute cette
réflexion là qui peut venir d'une
expérience qui est culturellement liée à
des individus qui ont été exclu par un
système de caste qui s'appelle les races
sont absents des conversations donc vous
pouvez comprendre que ça pour moi c'est
très difficile à devoir naviguer quand
j'essaie de faire des conversations même
quand je veux faire des chroniques parce
que faut mettre en place ce calcul
mathématiques là je dis mathématiques
parce que je pense beaucoup à inclusion
exclusion qu'on nous a appris qui peut
être la manière la plus neutre de faire
un diagramme de veine qui parle des
conversations multiples
et dans ce calcul là il manque beaucoup
de voix il manque beaucoup de d'opinions
beaucoup aussi de discussions et de
façon de faire très circulaire
présentement on parle d'opposition on
parle du pôle nord du Pôle Sud oui non
alors que la terre est ronde les
opinions sont multiples et c'est pour ça
qu'on discutait en cercle en tant que
communauté autochtone tout le monde avec
son opinion tout le monde avait son plan
de parole on donnait du temps aussi à la
parole c'était pas un cycle de nouvelles
un cycle de prise de position très
drastique c'était une conversation pour
que toutes les idées soient mises au
centre de la conversation et qu'on
puisse les regarder tous de façon égale
et voir qu'est-ce qui était le meilleur
pour la communauté donc quand on voit
des communautés qui se déchirent qui
excluent on voit présentement qu'un
grand danger pour la communauté bip
spirituelle un peu partout dans le monde
quand on veut exclure leur voix exclure
leur visibilité dans la communauté
dominante donc c'est encore le Pôle Nord
pour le sud là alors que le globe est
pas mal plus long que ça
donc c'est conversation là m'ont amené
vraiment à me rendre compte que dans
toutes nos discussions qu'il faut qu'on
mette en place cette compréhension qui
manque des voix qui manquent aussi une
sécurité de pouvoir discuter puis que à
cause du des dernières décennies en
France qu'est-ce qui est déjà en place
et parfait et qu'on incite juste une
pochette alors qu'on inclut dans le fond
dans un cercle une vision plus un angle
de plus alors quand on vous demandera si
vous êtes autochtone ou à l'automne
qu'est-ce qui est autochtone dans ce
sujet-là justement qu'est-ce qui n'est
pas autochtone qu'est-ce qui
n'appartient pas à une vision autochtone
pourquoi est-ce que je n'aurais pas le
droit de m'exprimer sur un sujet où il y
a amener justement une vision qui est la
mienne dans un cercle de société auquel
je participe
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a tellement
besoin que je garde mon mon pied dans la
réserve de ce qui est autochtone
pourquoi est-ce que cette vision là
dérange à ce point-là pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle peut pas être inclus dans une
plus grande conversation alors c'était
ma chronique pour cette semaine parce
que elle met en place d'autres sujets et
plus avance et plus les conversations se
complexifient et puis on se rend compte
qu'on peut pas juste vivre dans des
pochettes que c'est pochettes là
existent aussi dans la grande
conversation alors merci beaucoup pour
votre écoute merci de continuer à suivre
les chroniques de parole autochtone
parce que on avance toujours dans les
subtilités qu'il faut être qui doivent
être mis en place parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été présents pendant 6 ans alors je
souhaitais une belle semaine je vous
invite à regarder autour de vous à vous
demander qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
autochtone dans cette conversation et je
vous invite à partager cette opinion là
pour que les gens arrêtent de demander
de qu'on reste dans notre petite bulle
notre petite réserve d'idée et de savoir
alors que ce sont des savoirs alors
bonne semaine merci encore d'être à
l'écoute